ayant choisi lyon pour annoncer en 4
minutes et 40 secondes sa candidature
vraiment barre a tenu à passer toute la
journée dans la ville dont il est l'élu
chantal bretz a suivi les tout premiers
pas du nouveau candidat
document soit c'est parti officiellement
pour la première campagne présidentielle
du candidat barre dans l'après midi on a
fêté ça en famille madame bar aux côtés
de son époux et tout autour les
sympathisants lyonnais
raymond barre leur a demandé de l'aider
à convaincre pour gagner
l'adversaire est clairement désigné il
est socialiste et responsable du recul
de la france depuis sept ans notez le
bien s'étend et non pas cinq l'action de
jacques chirac depuis deux ans et donc
inclus dans ce bilan négatif et lorsque
l'ancien premier ministre se définit
comme n'étant pas un spécialiste de la
virevolte comme étant un homme
d'ouverture
n'ayant pas l'esprit de parti faut-il
comprendre là aussi qu'il marque sa
différence avec l'actuel premier
ministre